hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game from the 1939 buenos
aires olympiad it was a team event uh
and it's a game between jose rocablanca
and moshe cherniak a very strong polish
israeli grand master
it was suggested to me by jose carlos
santos uh via email so thank you for
that it's uh it's a very nice game and
of course we did not cover it during the
copa blanca saga uh because the
capoblanca saga only uh gets to the part
where capablanca defeats lasker and
that's it so we don't have any uh games
after that so maybe at some point i'm
going to do a you know post kappa blanca
saga that uh you know
do wells
with the the years after
that match but for now
we don't have that so this is one of the
games and it's the most interesting one
featuring a very very special move uh as
you'll see in the game so this uh we
even have a photo of the event this is
but this is not from this game they
played two games so as you can see here
kapolanka has the the black pieces uh
but uh you can enjoy the photo a little
bit you can see there's quite uh
quite the crowd has gathered here uh as
they you know usually did uh for for
chess events uh in those days nowadays
we just sit in front of our screens and
enjoy you know
bullet games
and
if you check out the quote above the
board it says i can see the headlines
capablanca is getting gold kava blanca
said this about himself after the first
game
because he uh gained the winning
advantage but he failed to
gain the full point and uh well uh it he
just wasn't very happy about that and he
said that uh uh next day the newspapers
will write about that how he's you know
gotten sloppy over the years uh but
after seeing the the second game that
will not be the case so let's check it
out and see what happens so capablanca
with the white pieces opens with e4 uh
we have c6 uh chennai goes for the karo
khan defense we have d for d5 and kappa
blanca goes for the exchange variation
of the car captures captures and now c
for the plan of attack or the pawn of
batwinik attack knight to c6 knight to
f3 and pinning the knight with bishop to
g4 uh capablanca trades in the center
here with c captures on d4 and it's all
with the very good reason of gaining a
tempo queen captures knight to knight to
c3 not the bishop obviously will win a
tempo at some point so queen captures
and now not knight to c3 right away
because that would allow black to just
capture here
even though it's a very interesting line
capablanca doesn't really think it's
worth it for example knight uh
c7 czech king the seven knight captures
an ats you pick up the rook but after
the bishop moves black will just pick up
the knight and well he will have two
knights for that rook on a1 uh not
something capablanca wants to play so
instead bishop to e2 defending and now
of course there's a little trick in the
position i've seen many people fall for
this uh the point is if you capture now
with the idea of capturing the d4 pawn
uh you could do this but bishop captures
on c6 check just removes the defender of
the queen and that's it white wins the
game so of course black did not play
that black played e6 we have castles and
now knight to f6 with knight to c3
finally gaining that tempo queen to a5
and now h3 attacking the bishop bishop
h5 and now a3 so slowly playing it
preparing b4 at some point
we have rook to d8 and now
the position has been reached many times
even in modern chess but nowadays the
engine gives the bishop to e3 as the
absolute strongest move although the
engine says it's only slightly better
than the move kappa blanca played
capoblanca played the g4 here
so incredibly shark uh opening up his
king's position like this uh but then
again who who are you going to trust an
engine or capoblanca so here we have
bishop to g6 and interestingly as of uh
move 12 this position has never been
reached again so bishop back to g6 and
now comes capablanca's idea so first g4
and now b4 and i always try to
emphasize the importance of b4 in every
chess game because it can be such a game
changer and this is uh no different uh
and what can black do here well
obviously black can capture on b4 and if
pawn captures you can capture the rook
on a1 so why is capablanca giving up the
pawn uh
well he obviously thought of something
and the best for black is to just move
the queen but black decided to accept
the challenge and you can't just accept
the challenge without really studying
the position so he studied the position
well and he decided to accept kappa
blanca's challenge so a captures and he
picks up the rook on a1 and now feel
free to pause the video and try to find
kappa blanca's idea and what he had in
mind while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on being a great
visionary as usual and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's a
queen to b3 now we're threatening to
move the bishop hopefully to a3 and to
win black's queen so this is something
that chanyang had to
well uh spot in order to accept the rook
on a1 so what did he find obviously not
that
he played the rook captures on these uh
d4 the point being that if knight
captures on d4 and knight captures uh
bishop to b5 check let's say because the
white queen is attacked and now we can
have a trade here captures captures
black castles and the queen on a1 is
very happy there's no way to trap it
there are many squares that the queen
can use to escape and black will be
better here so capablanca continues with
his plan bishop to a3 now the queen is
hanging and now what did black have in
mind here well bishop to c2
he wants to get the queen away from the
defense of the bishop here uh and of
course if rook captures we're just gonna
capture the queen on b3 and capoblanca
captures the bishop he decides to give
up the bishop on a3 even though he could
go for the end game but it's such a such
a tricky end game that uh i don't know
if you guys want to even see it i'm
going to show it to you i know some of
you want to see it uh so captures
captures now b5 uh pushing the the
knight back and but now bishop to d5
attacking the knight on f3
uh b captures on c6 bishop captures on
f3 uh we have bishop captures on f3 and
now rook to d3 with an attack on the
bishop and the knight now c captures on
b7 threatening promotion and now you
can't castle because the bishop covers
e7 and f8 so you have to move the king
king to d7 but now the problem is rook
to d1 and you will prevent the roof from
from capturing either of the pieces so
let's say captures captures now king the
c6 and this is the end game that would
be reached if both players played it
perfectly so it's not a lot but you do
have two bishops for a rook and okay you
will lose this past pawn but black is up
to pawn so maybe white can push for
something here
capablanca didn't think so so instead he
played queen captures in c2 we have
queen captures on a3 and now knight to
b5 so this was um
i think all of this was capoblanca's
plan all the way in the moment when he
played that b4 move uh the problem is
it's possible to defend this but only if
you spot the the most disgusting engine
line
ever seen and i'm going to show it to
you guys you can even pause the video if
you want but it's such a such a
disgusting line uh better maybe not even
try so here the idea is that if black
one black played queen captures on b4
but if you want to survive this you have
to play rook captures on g4 now after h
captures you have to play queen captures
on b4 now go for this pawn on g4
and now knight e5 at the now the pawn is
sufficiently defended you are attacking
the c6 knight and of course the knight
cannot move because you can't allow
queen to c8 to check so here blackwood
castle and after let's say knight
captures b captures attacking the knight
we're just going to capture on c6 knight
will capture on g4 and we get this
position where uh it's uh perfectly fine
uh you know for for uh for black not
nothing nothing wrong here uh you still
have your your pawn here and uh well you
just continue if knight captures on a7
you just start h5 h4 h3 and maybe
something happens so it was possible to
defend this but you have to spot this
rook captures and g4 move in the game
queen captures on b4 was played this is
the second best move but um yeah it is
not enough knight captures on the e4 was
played knight captures on d4 and now
again knight captures on d4 preventing
black from uh capturing on d4 because
queen to c8 check queen to d8 and now
bishop to b5 king to e7 now queen
captures on b7 check and after you move
the king somewhere it doesn't really
matter we're just going to bring the
rook here play rook c8 and that's it
game over
so after knight captures on d4 black
said all right i can't grab the knight
i'm just going to castle so you are up a
piece but i have two connected past
pawns so i i'm of course going to start
pushing them so here we have rook to d1
and now
what black uh uh failed to do is that he
failed to start pushing those pawns uh
though that's what past pawns are for
you have to push them otherwise they're
pretty much useless he went knight to d5
first probably uh interested in knight
to f4 going for the bishop maybe the h3
pawn may be trying to sneak the queen in
somehow uh so bishop to f3 getting rid
of both threats knight to f4 and now
king to h2 defending on h3 we have e5
attacking the knight here and knight to
f5 so you can see
by trying to create something here black
fails to do what he should have done and
that's pushing the past pawn so here he
plays g6 creates another weakness yes
you kick away the knight from f5 but you
weaken the f6 square and capablanca will
of course get the knight to f6 as soon
as possible knight to e3 we have knight
to e6 and now knight to d5 so that f6
square is now very very weak
queen to a3 attacking the bishop on f3
and now rook d3 defending we have queen
a1 rook to d1 attacks the queen queen
back to a3 capablanca repeats rook to d3
queen a1 but now of course he doesn't
repeat he plays queen to d2
and now what can black play well now
if you just start pushing for example
with a5 then queen to h6 and now
how do you defend against knight to f6
it's just very very ugly
so instead we have king to g7 blocking
this queen h6 move and now queen to e2
uh going uh well putting pressure on
this e5 pawn so f6 defending it so
you can move the the black queen from a1
and now queen to e3 again every move
with with a threat rook to a3 now is the
threat of winning that a7 pawn so a6 and
now rook back to d1 attacking the black
queen queen b2 and now knight to c3
we have knight to d4 now putting
pressure on this on this bishop here so
we have to be very careful okay the
queen is defending the bishop but that
can change very very quickly so here
kapablanca just played rook to b1 now
the queen has to move you're gonna pick
up the b7 pawn and black probably
thought okay i'm just going to move the
queen and capablanca will pick up the b7
pawn but he played queen to c2 and this
just makes it all the uh
all the more easier for capablanca to
win this game on the spot he did not
play bishop capture rook captures on b7
instead he played bishop to e4 and he
was in this position i moved 36 that
moshe cherniak resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
the queen is trapped you can see that
all of these squares are covered
discovered by the rogue by the knight by
the rook by the night by the queen by
the queen and well there's just nowhere
for this queen to go
and it's an easy move to miss if you're
you know thinking okay he's going after
the or b7 but regardless of the move the
position was completely lost so here we
see uh capoblanca playing in uh sort of
in great style starting after this rook
to d8 move so first i mean look at this
uh imagine this g4 bishop g6b for
playing h3g4 a3b4 this is not something
you see every day and uh well uh
luckily his opponent did not back down
from a challenge he accepted that he
grabbed the rook but then
uh capoblanca showed that uh well he was
just uh
a a better player in the in the given
position even though there was that one
in the disgusting engine line where
chernia could have fought back uh but uh
you know that's uh that those are the
kind of lines that you had to spot in
order to you know stand up to capoblanca
so okay he drew the first game but he
wins the second one and well i guess the
the headlines will not be writing
anything tomorrow other than capoblanca
unleashes a brilliant uh 14-move
combination starting with b4
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it and thank you again jose
carlos santos for suggesting such a such
a wonderful game uh thank you very much
for that uh like i said do join us
tomorrow in the arena there are over 1
000 players registered the link is in
the description below so do join us
we're going to have a lot of fun i'm
going to stream all you know the games
uh of course not all of them but uh
uh
as many as i can and well we're going to
have
a a good time i'm going to be reading
the chat quite a lot so you guys are
free to ask anything i'm going to try
and reply to to as many questions as
possible or just comments you know or
you know whatever you guys uh
are doing at the moment uh so once again
hope you guys enjoyed it let's check out
this photo one more time there you have
it uh very very nice
uh i would like to thank weaver sky
music emmanuel freitzel duncan weinkel
william fuller and the ayub for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
everything that's happening in the chess
world and of course checking up on your
wonderful suggestions uh thank you i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day